shows and movies time to have hulu
you know where you are you're in the
jungle cruise baby you're gonna have an
okay time it's it's all right
um it's australian commentaries we're
talking about jungle cruise if you
didn't get that uh i'm here with lana
and danielle we're gonna give you our
behind the scenes thoughts about the
video and our deep dive thoughts on the
movie show you some deleted scenes
respond to viewer comments and questions
so keep those coming in the chat and
then we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer it's gonna be a good one
um
okay jungle cruise
it happened uh we all watched it it it
flowed relatively easily i know lon you
you kind of were like i hate this i
thought it was
it was
i can understand hating it only because
it's so plain it's just like a real it's
just like an amusement park ride you get
on some things swing around and you get
off it really didn't make much of an
impression aside from jesse plemmons and
paul giamatti which we can talk about
but i found this to be a more or less
inoffensive but not great attempt at
doing a mummy at doing pirates of the
caribbean or god forbid indiana jones um
so
it was fine it wasn't good but it was
fine but what do you guys think
um it was pleasant yeah is that like a
good like it was uh uh you could you
could put it on while you're cleaning
yep good good doing something else while
you're watching movie uh unfortunately
we had to pay close attention
i feel like the rock has made a few
movies that i would term comedy adjacent
like central intelligence is on i i
recently watched it similar where it's
like
there's nothing funny like nobody
actually says funny things it's not
actually funny but everybody's like
acting like it's funny like their their
their dialogue sounds like banter
they're just it's just joke free banter
and like this was relentlessly like that
where it's like it's silly and zany and
like winking at you to let you know not
to take it seriously but like the only
actual jokes are jungle cruise jokes
like the the puns happen but there's no
other kinds of joke like it's just none
of the characters are funny i never
walked into this i never walked into
this thinking it would be a comedy i
thought this was going to be an
adventure movie but they're acting like
it's funny the movie's predicated upon
you finding these characters funny it's
not trying to get you to take it
seriously and like all the other movies
you mentioned are fun like the mummy's
funny
it's got funny beats in it yeah like
when the mom is trying to have banter
between like rachel weiss and ben and
frazier like it works it's actually
funny this is like the illusion of being
like watch this hand and then you don't
notice the other hand's not being funny
i think the comedy was the weakest uh uh
beats and then also uh you know
you can really tell
that they were not in any kind of jungle
for a movie
like they're not even sweating half the
time and like there's no bugs it's just
like it didn't feel real it felt very
much like you're on one of those uh
shaky box green screen rides rather than
like yeah
actually it's i know they shot some of
it in hawaii again not a jungle but um
most of it really felt cartoonish um and
i think we made that joke
we made that during the loki trailer
which and like loki did a better job of
it than this where it's like they kind
of get by by doing like expansive
digital establishing shots and then you
zero in and they could be you know
they're in burbank at a green screen
studio and like this definitely has that
like you get this beautiful vista of the
boat winding down the amazon and then
you zoom way into the boat and it's
pretty obvious that that is a boat that
is surrounded by a big green wall and
they're in glendale
[Laughter]
yeah glendale cruise
and like a lovely spot for a cruise i
enjoy glenn i uh before we get into it
park at the galleria i've walked to
america
i've been to disneyland like four or
five times in my life i've never been on
the jungle cruise is the jungle cruise
even at disneyland or is that disneyland
it's like one of the original disneyland
rides yeah i never did it
like walt designed the jungle cruise
like it was his idea okay um and it does
it satisfy you as a fan of the of the
ride the jungle cruise
not right well i guess yeah no i mean
like the jungle cruise ride is very much
like what the rock is doing with his
tour at the beginning of this movie like
it's not it's not a ride in a thrill
ride sense the jungle cruise it's you're
on a boat that's on a track going
through water there's animatronics and
then there's a guide who's doing bits
with you during the ride yeah i mean it
didn't disappoint me in that sense so i
wonder if fans of the ride were either
like more into it or less into it
because it did or didn't the ride has a
lot of like old-school charm and it it
does have the like what you expect when
you hear there's going to be a jungle
cruise movie if there's going to be a
skipper doing puns and it's going to be
you know period like that's probably
what it does the best is the opening 10
minutes where it's recreating the ride
it's like everything after that where i
was like oh it's trying to do pirates
and none of that felt like the ride at
all
yeah
um okay well let's uh take a ride down
the amazon with our jungle cruise on
this trailer hit it the following
trailer is rated s for spoilers yep
there's actually something you may not
have seen coming in the jungle cruise
movie i'm a shocked as you are
i did
pause
i will tell you the one thing i didn't
see coming is them using real-life
conquistadors as supporting characters
that's weak like making making so much
of the movie about the like brutal
colonization of south america isn't is
an interesting strategy but the rock
felt bad about it it's true it feels bad
well sort of in the moment
if he hadn't been cursed would he feel
bad about being a conquistador not real
yeah because in the during mid massacre
he had a change of heart oh that's true
oh it must be nice to be racially
ambiguous
it would be hard to get like halfway
into the amazon behind pizarro and not
figure out like what the score was i
will say you would have figured it out
pretty quick what these guys were up to
they were not subtle
spoiler all right keep going
spoiler for cunkies
[Music]
you've seen the rock make a jungle movie
you've seen the rock make a movie where
he teams up with a new friend to recover
a shiny artifact but have you seen the
rock make a jungle movie where he teams
up with a new friend to recover a shiny
artifact
yes return the jewel to the jaguar's eye
[Music]
twice you're going to take me to ocado
now get ready for the third rock bus
friend plus jungle plus shiny artifact
retrieval adventure in
jungle cruise
i guess
what is this rank for you guys in the
rock jungle pantheon is this uh top tier
bottom tier somewhere in the middle
i really liked the rundown
okay
number one rock of the jungle rundown i
gotta say i think the jumanji movies are
way better than this i i enjoy both
jumanji films more than john yeah i
gotta agree yes
sub jumanji for me so yeah because those
are they've got a good comic premise
like all those actors getting to act
like the kids and whatever is a lot
funnier than any of the stuff they came
up with for this one yeah and
lon we were we were slacking about this
uh a couple weeks ago is like how
what does and doesn't count as a jungle
movie because there's plenty of movies
where he visits the jungle but it's not
a jungle movie yeah he goes to like uh
you know the backwoods his family home
and samoa or wherever it was in hobbs
and shaw and it's like jungle adjacent
but right that doesn't count even though
they're in like a
like a and yeah a heavily wooded area in
rampage does that count yeah and like
mummy scorpion king has some like
they're near a giant like it's more
desert but there are some jungles but it
doesn't quite get there yeah
i think hercules too has at least one
jungle adjacent sequence but it didn't
feel sufficiently like a jungle
dwayne of the jungle uh all right i mean
it looks like a guy that would be in the
jungle i mean i i guess i get that like
that's why you gotta have muscles like
that if you're gonna survive the job
all right keep going
that's maybe five percent actual ride
and 95 corny jokes is now an adventure
movie that's maybe five percent actual
adventure and 95 corny jokes ma'am don't
forget to collect your baggage i'm only
kidding he's behind you from some of
atlanta's most excited from the right
spring locales comes a boat trip crammed
with more painfully awkward banter than
the entertainment lineup on a budget
carnival cruise where the only thing
tougher to escape than the ancient
curses are the endless punchline
adjacent arguments if i have to bring
you back dead it's 15 000. why should i
pay more dead dead i'd have to carry it
you should give up you should give up
the guitar get it hold on come on got it
thank you i don't it's okay to be
nervous it's your first time
i've done this hundreds of times i don't
know how to take that phrase this is
special would you like me to give it a
wiggle yeah absolutely not yeah i could
pull around the back and give it a one
two we're good first of all i thought
that was i mean that went on so long
that it became funny again to me yeah
kept talking about the uh sword penis um
but that's exactly the hobbs and shaw
thing where they like go back and forth
and you keep like waiting for like the
punch line and it's like no the joke is
just that they're arguing the thing is i
don't see this as being any
different from
the
uh pattern and rhythm and
quality of like a marvel movie i'm sorry
like that's the kind of tone and jokes
that they make in every marvel movie and
like it's just like it it's like it gets
a sensible chuckle you know at its best
but i mean i i don't necessarily
disagree with you it just depends on the
marvel movie like i think there are
marvel movies that that are funnier than
this but there are indeed marvel movies
that do develop this kind of field for
sure kind of the disney house style is
like we know you're watching a movie and
we know you're probably thinking about
this in a scene like this so we're gonna
take time to kind of turn to you and say
like uh you know what
we both expected this to happen that
wasn't cool wink yeah
i mean i just i guess i just found this
variation of it particularly tiresome
but what's also galling is that i know
from other films that the rock and emily
blunt and jack whitehall like they're
all funny like they all could be funny
like they were just
i think so i think it's the material
letting them down danielle what's the
hardest emily blunt has ever made you
laugh
i think when she married john krasinski
oh why do they do
wow
that was just the first thing that came
to my mind no john krasinski hate here i
think he's great wow danielle i need
coffee
but i mean like devil wears prada she's
fine she's really funny
do you want to move on or do you want to
dive in on that note yeah really tell us
more
no no i just feel terrible now i'm just
a bad person good news yeah whatever
whatever bro
jim fit everybody gym face all right
keep going
no we're good oh my god is that your
idea of a joke that is not funny correct
meet frank a riverboat captain inspired
by the hgnh in humphrey bogart's name
he's an actual colonizer
with more bad puns than our starring by
the way this is briefly uh the african
queen great uh old school adventure
movie uh yeah
uh humphrey bogart and elizabeth taylor
i think right no i'm gonna try again
we'll give one more try
uh help me out lon catherine hepburn
catherine hepburn thank you thank you um
and i guess we can get into it later but
like it's a dynamic that works because
it's like salty
riverboat captain and like fancy lady
and like exactly naturally exactly
exactly salty riverboat captain and
plucky go get him uh archaeologist
adventurer like they would seem to get
along or be sort of on the same page
from the get-go but they kind of have to
force the awkward banter and the rivalry
uh
totally agree completely agree with uh
what's your point there i also think it
works better if the leads have some kind
of like romantic chemistry
[Laughter]
before this i used to work in an orange
juice factory but i got canned
couldn't concentrate
yeah they put this they have
concentrated orange juice no i looked
this up they didn't invent concentrated
oranges
all the time anachronistic folks
sure the rock does it and it's charming
but if i keep giggling to myself in the
proto-section of trader joe's suddenly
it's concerning
watch as the rock really delivers on the
physicality
sort of nails the drama what will happen
to you
i get to make a choice
and i choose to rest and speaks the
tiniest amount of 4th grade spanish so
we know he's from
in a role he was destined to play
an actual rock hope he didn't take the
opportunity for granite
do you think he was petrified before
this scene
or does he get enough stone cold sleep
often
when headstrong
hires frank for a trip down the river
the chemistry is undeniable between the
rock and his boat
the rock and her gate i mean we could
just talk about it now um
i
don't know what to say about the people
who previous to watching this movie were
giving it reviews like the chemistry is
undeniable between the rock and empty
fun
i don't know what they're watching this
was
i i just can't take the rock seriously
with like another normal looking human
being i feel like you need to pair him
with like sofia vergara or like another
like like an actual amazon like gal
gadot or something like that i just it
just looks like i don't know it looks
like an action figure and a human and it
just doesn't look like they fit together
um
i don't know maybe because the rock is
like what a six-year-old boy fantasizes
about like looking like someday is that
there's just something kind of sexless
about him like he just is too
muscular and like smooth i don't know i
think it's i think it's also part of the
performances that he give like the rock
definitely has his like
voice and mode and it's like and he's
the same way with men and women and i
think that's part of the appeal of the
rock as a character and how they use
them in these movies but it does also
mean like it's it seems like he
sometimes has difficulty switching modes
like okay this is how i played the scene
with like all of these other people but
now i'm the romantic lead and like you
know like i don't know if he's quite
switching modes when he's with emily
blunt versus
you know like jack whitehall yeah no
it's like the exact same banter banter
banter and then at the end they like
kiss and it's like not because it's none
of the like it's not like romancing the
stone banter where it's like you know
kind of like they like each other but
they're this is how they're working
through it right yeah they keep trying
to like force it by like showing a
couple of like them uh staring clearly
not at each other um but just like
close-ups of them staring at something
um and making kind of like small eyes
and that's how you know
you know or like
um and then like putting them together
and like those awkward things like when
they're down there because it's supposed
to be sexy when she's down in the cage
and he's feeding her air
like that's supposed to be hot
but instead i'm it's just it really does
just come off like cpr like it doesn't
come off it's like oh
like he's helping her but also their
lips are touching and this is the moment
we've been waiting for the entire movie
like i did not expect that they were
gonna be a thing like it never even
crossed my brain it could have just as
easily been johnny knoxville instead of
emily blood and the rock would have
played that scene exactly the same he is
paired with johnny knoxville and walking
tall that's why i thought um that that
was when that underwater scene was when
emily blunt was overcoming her only
character flaw she can't swim
it's like oh crap we wrote another
perfect human being again
what's wrong with her uh she can't swim
perfectly
that's like uh
well they couldn't they wanted her to do
parkour so she couldn't be clumsy
i know but she was clumsy in a couple
scenes at the beginning like she like
bumps some stuff when she's trying to
sneak around and that's the that's
usually the go-to is like yeah that's
good stuff right there what a klutz no
no man would ever love her she's like
it is weird because they're they're so
obviously playing like her brother is
this kind of you know like dandy like
over the top you know like he's only
ever been in the city and has no idea
how to be in the jungle and you would
think that would you could give her that
characteristic like you could still ever
be like a brilliant researcher and all
the other stuff who's posh yeah right
but like yeah just make her like because
that's also the african queen dynamic
and it's totally what i expected and
then yeah making her just like exactly
rachel vice from the mummy where she's
also like this great adventurer up for
anything perfect physical specimen
basically superhero you're just not
giving them much of a dynamic to play
with or if she is then make the then
make the rock uh uh paul giamatti um
have paul gimani literally just have
those two guys switch characters yeah
i'm in
the rock it's a ludicrous italian
stereotype
as fun as like the pants jokes are i
gotta say i always love a good moment
where the chicks gotta break off her
heels and slit down her skirt so she can
get stuff done
yeah they got a lot of mileage out of
those pants
oh boy they love that they love it i
love that joke uh all right let's keep
playing and her gay brother had a
girlfriend once she was cross-eyed
didn't work out
we could never see eye to eye
the rock and his pet jaguar you're the
best cat i've ever had the rock and his
child servant
really anyone except the rock and lily
houghton bro get off me what are you
doing i'm trying to get traction this is
ridiculous just leave me alone that was
a disaster you're too heavy still
everyone
says a woman with dual phds and body and
parkour nothing will stop her from
joining the he-man woman haters club a
tribe who's chief a lady
someone correctly pointed out in the in
the comments that uh around this time in
england it would have been like five
years removed from queen victoria
a woman
uh eddie everybody's monocles popped off
at the same moment and i forgot actually
at the uh
at the very end if you can recall do
they actually bring back anything from
that tree or any like proof that any of
this actually happened
or is it just like their word
yeah i think it's just their word i
think it's just uh jack whitehall being
like
screw y'all yeah yeah we totally saved
the day like why would they buy it any
more than they they were they thought it
was ridiculous the first time they
presented to the society they must bring
i'm blanking exactly what happened they
must have brought back some kind of
evidence of i'm uh looking up yeah
because
my definitely go and get get like the
final word on the the he-man society so
i just don't remember exactly how
yeah
anyways guessing she must have like
published something that proved it and
that's what i said
they get the they think they have the
last pedal and she uses it but then the
moon like cracks back out and there's
one more bloom that she can grab and
that's what she takes back yeah she does
have one of the flowers to bring back
with her and then they're like oh you
can join the royal society now and she's
like get bit got it all right okay keep
going
not even if that means stealing an
entire civilization's most prized
natural resource and using it
exclusively to help our new bestie with
benefits wow they really stick it to
that indigenous tribe the imagineers are
gonna have to shut this right down for
some retooling again
is the dark history of european
imperialism not fun enough for you then
climb aboard for a supporting cast of
cut-offs featuring jack whitehall as
disney's eighth first live-action gay
character with a perfectly
self-contained coming out moment for
easy chinese sensor removal paul
giamatti as the guy from the pizza boxes
and the main villain princio prince what
prince
jesse plymouth he's not exactly a nazi
but he's not exactly naughty
he's like if we're hershey's was a
fashion um this is just the classic uh
collapsing of world war one and world
war ii germany together they're just
always basically evil nazis
kaiser wasn't like a great guy like i
don't know but like neither were the
kings and queens of europe at the time
everybody was just trying to fight each
other to colonize places like this
faster he the only difference in terms
of how jesse flemings is playing this
role is the uniform like if you put him
in a nazi uniform you would be like yup
there he is yeah but i did appreciate
that this is what saved the movie from
being just unwatchable to me is how
these two jesse clemens and paul
giamatti were giving it 900 i know
that's not possible but they managed to
like every line of dialogue every scene
they were like sweating bullets and just
like screaming in these uh
just cartoonish accents and
gosh darn it if it didn't didn't make me
laugh every time
uh yeah
you gotta respect those guys for just
recognizing that what this is and just
going no leaving leaving it all on
screen leaving nothing behind in the
town yeah yeah
um it would be very boring without
without those two pedigreed actors um
yeah i feel like if paul giamatti was
not italian this would be deeply
offensive like this yeah only because
his last name is giamatti that he's
allowed to do this i like forgot that he
was in the movie so as soon as like that
happened i was like i gotta look up this
actor and then i was like oh it's paul
giamatti they just
yeah
yes they did um
[Laughter]
herzog was a fascist who took orders
from a bee the arrow hit
the arrow hit yes show me show me where
well at least the movie doesn't feel the
need to point out that it's funny that
he's talking to it we're taking orders
from a bee hey movies please stop
pointing out the funny thing we get it
so if you like the first pirates of the
caribbean film disney's hoping it's
because you like movies where a boat
captain and a headstrong tomboy lady
clash and then they run across some
nasty europeans who are actually
immortal so the captain pretends to die
to save the others but he turns out to
be immortal too and the headstrong
tomboy lady ends up saving him in the
end savvy
starring
steamboat silly
between a rock and his hard place
waking snakes we got that in brotherhood
friday nine lights
a tribe called test
and contractually obligated reminders
that the rock is swole i wouldn't trust
you as far as i could throw you which
clearly isn't very far because you are
huge big strong boy gosh there's a lot
of you isn't there yeah there is
raiders of the lost bark
it's true you're looking for a tree
folks seriously it's great that this and
hobbs and shaw are finally ending the
rock's iconic run of never getting
action in his own action movies but can
some high school drama teacher step in
and teach him to stage kiss
really weird it's a really weird takes
where they tried it but they
it's like um
uh michael jackson and imani in uh um
yes i remember the time remember the
time video yeah yeah
sometimes it's best to just not show it
yeah just put that arm right up just
yeah like give us the three quarters
perspective on it that's fine
some actors have like a stunt stand-in
he needs a kiss standard just like a
really good guy
but who's very sensual a kissable body
double
um
right said fred can we see what that
guy's up to yeah
sensual rock yeah jewel rock is very
sexy um
or is he you be the judge uh thank you
guys for watching um this is on this
trailer commentaries you know that
already hit like and hit subscribe and
ring that give that bell a ding-a-ling
so you don't miss another thing
oh that rhymes yeah like i did
so um
have some out takes let's do some
outtakes what did we cut out of this
frankly my dear i will make a damn hansa
kimbo
america del surly
the eternals
dope francis
edge of yesterday
so you think you can pants conquistador
latin hex hunch and judy garland
mcgregor
dandy man travels with my sister
kidzfop chappie
when life gives you plemons do you even
boat bro
fuhrer the submariner kaiser droll
the italian
you've brought the greater joy to this
old italian stereotype traitor scam
agent barter
local natives
boat trap
overboard
romancing the rock
i ship it
it's time for amazon ex
the way of the pawn
don't the rock the boat
i didn't mean you gotta say it was fun
to see the rock and show williams got
reunite yes
that's awesome ah those two are great
together
it doesn't need to be coming off because
it's tattoo ink it'll come off
eventually
in a few decades tattoos stay visible
because the needle pushes them under
your top layers of skin frank not
because the ink is magic it never washes
off you've been alive for hundreds of
years bro
uh we're missing
we're missing some other uh uh uh
deleted bits and pieces here because i
know we had more uh the rock as a rock
the rock as a rock went on for a really
long time
you'll have to write your own in the
comments for rock as an actor yeah i
think i've made a few contributions even
before we we cut it down yeah um oh well
uh yeah you can fill those in in your
own brain um
i also noticed uh one thing that didn't
make it in is
do you think that was a nod to aguirre
wrath of god to name it it is no he's
he's playing he's playing agira who is a
historical figure yeah so yes it is
edgar ramirez in this movie is in fact
playing the exact same character that
klaus kinski is playing in the classic
herzog jesse plemons is playing warner
herzog
but they even went so far as all the
other the other conquistadors who are
with agira who come back to life they're
all named after real guys like they
really went back and it's a whole group
of actual historical cookies now in
fairness all these guys were in peru not
brazil so they messed that up for the
movie but you know close enough so
easter eggs for all you big uh
conquistador yes if you if you really
hate the incas you can celebrate the
people who wipe them off the face of the
earth
by watching jungle cruise on to uh on to
the viewer comments so uh uh speaking of
which prince of poopoo writes there's
some cool easter eggs about the ride in
the movie and vice versa the disney
parks have this massive cinematic
universe that like 90 of people don't
know about i don't know but i just know
that um the most recent time i went to
disneyland i saw way too much johnny
depp at the pirates of the caribbean
he's around every corner yeah he's in
there a lot yeah uh i did notice one
there's one part where they're reading
one of the journals and they cite dr
albert falls in this which is a
reference to a joke from the ride
because they're like we're coming up on
schweitzer falls named after the famed
naturalist dr albert falls but of course
twice
um so there's a bunch of stuff like that
where if you know the banter from the
ride they're making references yeah
um
well let's see uh
what uh well
they
let's see where is that where'd that
question go oh um adam hallbert writes
uh what's anyone's favorite jesse
plemon's villain role because he's he's
putting together quite the collection oh
i it's a game tonight yeah
it's game night yeah it's game night
he's destroying game night it's so funny
i mean he's great in that black mirror
episode too that would be like my second
pick that was a great one yeah but oh
man i love him so much in game night
what an amazing yeah he plays a great
dead-eyed psychopath like uh ryan brings
up todd from breaking todd from breaking
bad of course and el camino he was
really good in elgin yeah oh that was
great yeah he's great he's just like who
knew he's so good landry would be one of
our generations
right
and it's not a villain role but um that
i'm thinking of ending things charlie
kaufman movie he did on netflix is
incredible i think it's a well that's a
that's a whole other i mean it's on the
edge yeah
uh john bainbridge asks what's the
jungle percentage requirement for a
jungle movie um great question great
question
i feel like the main setting would have
to be the jungle for it to be a rock
jungle like he's got to be going to the
jungle as the primary
right yeah i'd say like
just it's got to be around half of it
yeah at least 50 percent junk yeah
yeah
carl jung over here yeah
it's a jungian archetype yeah you gotta
be if you're not in the jungle
characters should be talking about the
jungle and when they're gone
uh radar city update channel asks uh how
much breakfast cereal do you think the
rock could eat in a day
oh my god what a day
with milk or without
mmm yeah i think you need the milk but
it's his strategy he probably wants to
do if you're doing it all day you
probably want to mix it up go dry wet
dry wet first unless it's like captain
crunch because you would cut up your
mouth real bad you needed
yeah the oral health part of it i'd say
12 12 boxes and i would get far far away
from any bathroom uh
within i feel like it's way more than i
think like 12 boxes is just like that's
the that's the start that's like it's
like a palette
because he's used to yeah he's used to
eating like big things of protein like
yeah wasn't he one of those people who
like around the time mark wahlberg was
telling us all like his ridiculous
schedule the rock was like here's
everything i eat and everyone was like
that's like a family's worth yeah no
it's disgusting how much the eats it
it's so much easier to eat like a
steamed chicken than it is to eat like
bowl after bowl of hard dry cereal i
don't know i think that
depends on yeah yeah um
okay uh moving on um
sarah q asks what's the best ride based
on a movie
or the best movie based on a ride
right there they've made a bunch of like
oh like terminator 4d or whatever is
pretty sweet at universal yeah yeah
that's true uh it's not a ride but i'm
always gonna say the water world
spectacular oh yeah one of the best
things i've ever seen i mean i guess i
would say star tours that's probably my
all-time favorite like movie inspired
ride mm-hmm
um but i do love that water world action
stunt spectacular it used to be the
miami beach bones of the miami bikes yes
yeah they both fly planes over the over
the set at the end yeah if they ever
shut that if they turn that into fast
and the furious or whatever it is that
they're going to do next it's fine you
just got to keep having that like a a
boat or a plane yeah or a car
a city plane has to jump into the pool
at the end yeah i insist
yeah mostly the rides based on movies
are usually not great although i've only
done like southern california theme
parks they usually are like you get in a
box and then there's like screens around
you and it shakes while it shows you
scenes of you know optimus prime
screaming at you so it's right like the
simpsons ride or the back to the future
right the mummy actually built one out
which is cool there's a real mummy
there's some mommy love in the chat yeah
and jurassic park is like you go you
know that's broken
it's always broken
and then there's the one that's on the
tram which was very upsetting to me
because like it it's like 40 and that
things happen and like it spit in my
hair it was very upsetting that's not
good it was not people extra i mean all
those disneyland rides are kind of based
on movies like mr toad's wild ride is
based on a movie and like the you know
so you could pick any of those the kong
this kong skull island ride i did in
orlando was very disappointing oh i
didn't even know that was arrived yeah
no yeah i was not i was not pleased with
the skull island ride i would say it's
not a ride but just harry potter world
in general is probably like the most
successful
like movie adaptation to a theme park
well in florida they do have that ride
now right like
hagrid yeah rides around the beasts or
whatever yeah we're riding on a little
big little bicycle with some wings
because the motorcycle like his
motorcade yeah yeah that cars ride at
disneyland is pretty fun too oh the cars
ride is actually awesome yeah i really
like that one yeah i know eric here for
here so we gotta we gotta follow up with
this when we have eric around because he
also could probably yeah we need more uh
about this actually i think we have
plenty we have enough disney adults uh
on staff here i was gonna say yeah well
we have we have like two we're good i
think we're good
um all right we'll close with this uh do
you have a pitch for a splash mountain
movie any ideas for how we could or
really take it any any disneyland ride
you can um so there's this guy named
uncle raymond i don't think we should i
don't think
there you go there's your pitch but it's
that that one's locked in the back of
the disney vault you know like the vault
has like the little mini safe inside the
vault with its own key that's where
songs
yeah they still do holla presidents
that can make like an interesting movie
just like all of the presidents
yeah all of the all the presidents just
like come alive maybe it's like hamilton
they all start rapping yeah okay i did
kind of think they would do that you
could take like rare rabbit and rare
bear just like excise all the other
stuff and like make a cartoon movie
about those characters i always figured
they would do that and they never yeah
yeah yeah probably for the best just
like for them just just like that's
gonna be princess of the frog now and
we'll all be better off for it yeah
um all right this has been fun it always
is always a good time with y'all uh and
thank you so much for watching please
come back next week where we will do a
deep dive
um in a movie that's just it's going to
be hot it's going to be a hot one people
oh yeah
so that's why
it's going to be very smooth
[Laughter]
some things about it are also smooth
just like the ocean under the moon well
yeah uh ocean not so much um so have you
ever watched juliet well uh well come on
uh we'll see well it's more well we
don't want to give it away we'll see you
next week thank you for watching bye-bye
this episode was brought to you by hulu
[Music]
you